vautier qui attend un bonsoir merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
la fédération nationale des pompes
funèbres appelle à ne pas être la grande
oubliée de la profession et être
prioritaires en vue de la campagne de
vaccination pourquoi une telle de monde
aujourd'hui
nous craignons c'est délicat pour
certains équipements de protection
durant la première phase des travaux une
profession du week-end parce que pas
forcément la santé donc prioritaire et
nous souhaitons simplement que cette
campagne de vaccination est très
important de les recenser cinéma
différent car on intervient au delà des
gens dans le bus dans les ehpad et on
est forcément du coup très exposé donc
du coup vous êtes une profession à
risques c'est ça oui exactement
classés parce que les premiers équipe
assez vite
il ya eu des réunions
interministérielles ou intégrer je suis
derrière on était également la
conséquence dans la boule de l'épidémie
est aujourd'hui en ligue 1 on revendique
la nécessité de nous intégrer de delhi
dépassant servante dans la campagne de
vaccination vous avez dit vingt-cinq
mille employés de services funéraires en
entend 20000 quel est le réel chiffres
et les taux à le les personnels enfin
vos confrères qui sont en contact avec
les défunts attendue du coc u19 leur
famille parfois infecter
du coup quelques chiffres concernant vos
confrères en termes de cadre coronavirus
et même de décès liés à cette maladie
vous en connaissez aujourd'hui notre
profession et hand habilité et parfois
opérée par l'équipe nationale avec plus
ou moins des fonctions de marc henri dès
compliqué d'avoir quantité exacte de sa
part y est on est dehors devraient avoir
droit à 24 travaillé de près ou de loin
en contact avec les défunts et les deux
lignes
pour ce qui est du personnel des
établissements aux funéraire de nombreux
ont été touchés on n'a pas de décès
dénombrés clairement sein des effectifs
je pense ça serait compliqué de tenir
des chiffres avant quelques mois
toutefois la réalité est clair au delà
du conte à gré il est dépeint comme je
vous le disais on est au contact des
établissements de santé on rentre dans
les états ont établi et donc de facto ou
des sources de propagation est
importante elle fait de tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé comme ça c'est pour
être entendu je suppose par le
gouvernement vous êtes en contact
également avec avec matignon ou avec le
ministère de la santé à ce sujet le
sujet qui a touché plusieurs ministères
et ministère de la santé le ministère de
l'intérieur parce que c'est notre truc
unicef de rattachement également les
collectivités locales dont il ya une
réunion analystes et avec les
collectivités locales toutes espèces ou
d intégrer un professionnel du culot
on peut aussi fait rentrer nos volontés
ne pas d'atouts billet on a voulu
accentuer et écrite et les médias pour
avoir un certain poids dames des comptes
sur le sujet est ce que votre activité a
été débordée depuis le début de la
pandémie
on a eu des vagues aujourd'hui le débat
est moins forte que la première au
niveau national en réponse à deux
puisque les plus de 6% de dessaler
l'hymne national ce qui est ce qu'il est
conséquent mais ce qui a surtout aidé
extrêmement attention certaines périodes
de près de + 35 60 décès sur mois
d'avril
de plus que l'année passée donc il ya eu
des vagues très fort en effet mais oui
d'une manière globale et on est sur un
système de bacs et du pic merci gauthier
qui attend d'avoir répondu à la question
je rappelle que vous êtes le porte
parole de la confédération des
professionnels du funéraire et de la
marbrerie